what is an anime that you would want a
high budgeted highly produced remake of
if given the choice I'll go first my
personal pick is berserk it is a crime
against humanity for a manga to look
this incredible for a story to be this
emotionally and well written to not only
not have a dedicated go-to anime
adaptation worthy of the material but
for it to also be very much a story that
has gone unnoticed by the vast majority
of casual viewers berserk is so damn
good that it should be as ubiquitous as
Game of Thrones and Harry Potter but
it's not and that's a crime against
humanity I'd kill for this story to get
a terrific anime adaptation of its
entire story